the sink head says which is the demarchy
product for us this year it has a
40-millimeter driving it it utilizes
clear technology a lot of the wireless
headsets GCSEs are utilizing bluetooth
which was originally created for
telecommunication so it compresses the
files and it lowers the actual sound
quality so clear technology allows us to
have the headset 50 feet away from its
source and music without losing CD
quality sound because I've bought
headsets in the past that have been
eacute for hip hop music they had really
heavy bass but not so good sound quality
when you played it with other genres and
music I put an envoy equalizer on the
sink headset that allows you to bass
boost and for you to skip forward and
rewind actual songs from the actual
headset I wanted to balance it out
because the process of me writing a song
and creating a song sometime I'm
inspired by the production so it's
important for me to try and have the
general public hear the song the way I'm
actually hearing it in the studio I've
tried to offer something that would be
visible to general public as a stronger
quality like the headsets are
demonstrated for you durability was
really important for me right now the
available SMS audio com and you know we
have
successful the soft launched in december
we did pretty good so i'm excited and
the CES has been amazing the coverage
that I've got since I've you know launch
day he speaks for herself I'm all over
the place